une situation sanitaire toujours
préoccupante en tunisie alors que la
campagne de vaccination s'accélère peu à
peu au rythme des dons internationaux
trente quatre mille cinq cent soixante
deux personnes ont été vaccinées durant
la seule journée du 15 juillet portant à
plus de deux millions deux cent mille le
nombre de tunisiens vacciner 11% reçu
deux doses tandis que 5% seulement une
première dose sur près de 12 millions
d'habitants selon les autorités
sanitaires tunisiennes au moins dix sept
mille personnes ont perdu la vie depuis
le début de la pandémie
après l'appel a lancé par tunis la
solidarité internationale se met en
marche
l'algérie l'egypte le maroc encore la
france entre autres se sont succédé ces
derniers jours pour apporter leur
soutien au pays près de 3 millions de
doses de vaccins ont été livrés ces 72
dernières heures ainsi que plusieurs
hôpitaux de campagne
des unités de réanimation des
concentrateurs d'oxygène et différents
matériels médicaux en france le
secrétaire d'état chargé du tourisme des
français de l'étranger et de la
francophonie jean baptiste lemoyne
indiqué ce jeudi que la france ferait
don à la tunisie d'un demi million de
doses du vaccin johnson & johnson
écouter on aura donné plus d'un million
de vaccins ensuite des concentrateurs
d'oxygène sont accordés à la tunisie
en tout depuis juin on sera plus de 85
tonnes d'équipements médicaux apportés
en solidarité à nos amis et à ce peuple
frère de tunisie la présidente de l' île
de france valérie pécresse a également
annoncé sur son compte twitter que sa
région va accorder une aide de 100 mille
euros à la maison de la tunisie pour
aider à l'équipement des hôpitaux
tunisiens écouter face à l'appel à
l'aide de la tunisie et la région ile de
france répondra présente nous
apporteront une aide de 100 mille euros
à la maison de la tunisie pour aider à
l'équipement des hôpitaux
pas question de laisser nos partenaires
tunisiens seul selon l' oms la tunisie
enregistre actuellement le taux de
mortalité djokovic 19 le plus élevé dans
le monde arabe
le bassin méditerranéen mais aussi
l'afrique